for you know coming back to us so what's
happened in between new you did the the
comedy movies with Governor of
California how hard the mind of the
Machine just to get back into Terminator
yeah first of all I was really looking
forward to it but I did not know if they
would do another Terminator if I get
asked back or what because as you know
what happens to the James Bond movies
and Batman movies
it was often they just switched him out
with you know newer people and so I was
really you know very happily surprised
when I got a call and said will you do
another Terminator and I said yeah if
the script is great of course and so the
script was fantastic then it start
preparing myself for it I had to gain 10
pounds to kind of have the same kind of
a build again the same frame that had in
1984 and or isn't it was really fun to
get back into this character you know
I've done it three times so it was not
kind of like starting from scratch it's
like riding a bicycle you get right back
into it and it's the only thing that was
different here was because this
Terminator now has been around for a
longer period of time he has been longer
with human beings he has adopted some
human behaviors but when he whenever he
tries to act like a human being he fails
and miserably and and that's of course
what creates them the comic relief all
cinema and you've got a new catchphrase
in this film are you right or does
there's many a be the first word and you
should know that you never know when you
do a movie which of the lines are going
to be repeated out there later on I mean
the audience picks that the fans pick
that so when I said I'll be back I have
no idea that this line ever will be
repeated by anybody
so LaVista baby and orders that I mean I
had no idea so we really don't know what
is the catchphrase in this movie yeah I
mean people said like the line and I
said you know old but not obsolete
deadline for instance but they know it
because their honor if she's equally
iconic so how did you have to gotta get
buff for that did you have to go to me
and she's the badass she is pretty
badass yeah I mean I needed a lot of
physical strength just to simply carry
the guns that I didn't have at the
beginning of their movie yeah by the end
was fine I could pick up a grenade
launcher and do like 22 takes that was
fine nice no but you right well I mean I
have to say I was really amazed in the
kind of shape that she got into and you
know because she really spent hours and
hours working with a personal trainer
working with a gun expert and weapons
expert working with the stunt
coordinators and the stunt guys
understand women there I mean she really
put in many many hours to prepare for
this film physically and then of course
the acting needed even more time
[Laughter]
[Music]